the student of Ashish and mama then
Ellie okay so this is how we have been
thinking about algorithms for the last
many decades so we have data and that's
consumed by an algorithm and that
produce an output and this algorithm is
supposed to compute some function that
we are interested in fact this falls
into the classic of setting of
algorithms that you assume the data is
fixed or a stationary so it doesn't
change at all and the algorithm has
unrestricted access to the data say in
the P remodel of kanack you can access
any location the data and then make some
accommodations and it produce output but
over the last few years we have really
slowly realized that this model is not
sufficient for many real-world problems
and that has led to a huge collection of
more contemporary models of computation
I just a few here just to give you a
flavor of what kind of directions people
have been looking at so one is online
algorithms there you have the algorithm
sitting there and input data arrives one
by one but the key restriction here is
that the algorithm once it makes a
decision on an input it cannot revoke
its decision so the decisions are
irrevocable so as soon as it sees the
next data item it makes a decision
whether to say updated data structure or
do some computations and then after that
it has no choice but to live with that
that's uh Nigel only logarithms and more
recently there are there's a family of
algorithms course training algorithms
where the restriction on the algorithm
is on the amount of space accuses so the
data is so big that no algorithm has the
capacity to store all of it in memory
and then do the processing so not like
the traditional model therefore an ideal
way such an algorithm would operate
would be to take the data and then say
for example compute a succinct sketch or
a sixteen representation of it and then
perform computations on that that forms
streaming algorithms and if you trade
space for time you get what are called
sub linear algorithms
but again you have the entire for
example the graph sitting and you don't
have time to explore the diagraph
instead you should spend some linear
amount of time sub linear in the input
size to query the graph and do some
perform some computations and finally in
a completely different line of thinking
we also have algorithmic game theory
where you actually a algorithm actually
influences how the system behaves so
that's a completely different line of
thought so the point here is that while
we have most of us have been happy with
working with a classical model of
computation the modern data needs which
you see the next slide dicket's us to
move into think about some other ways of
data or the computation itself in fact
the whole many of these things are the
previous models I I put up are motivated
by evolving data so you can think of
beta as a snapshot of nature but the
nature changes slowly over time it
changes but the changes are sort of slow
and the requirement behaved is that we
need to keep up with such changes but
constantly observing the nature and
adjusting solution based on new
observations so that's data for example
think of the data being like the
position of all the stars in the galaxy
they do of course change but we need to
algorithm has to do some computations on
these positions there it has to do that
by keeping them with such changes by
trying to probe or trying to query the
nature and try to get some data from
that of course this is not feasible
computationally because it may not even
be possible to track all the changes
because changes can happen without
notifying the algorithm that's the first
thing a second is changes can occur
anywhere no we're not in a position
where we can try to observe predict the
changes will occur so it can occur
anywhere in the system so we have no way
of doing it efficiently and finally in
as you see in some applications we are
not really interested in the changes per
se what we really care about is some
particular function we want to compute
and as long as the function we want to
compute
has some guarantees of correctness or
goodness then we are happy so we don't
want to track each and every change that
occurs in the system so you only care
about the what what it does to our
problem of interest that's the that's
motivation and here actually concrete
examples so let's take web pages of
course all of us know there are like
billions of web pages and even now
pencil even hundreds of millions of
hyperlinks links between my pages change
on a daily basis right so imagine a
search engine company the natural
question is which portions of the web
should I focus such that I have to crawl
that portion on a daily basis to keep up
with as many changes as possible say for
example to compute page rank there's a
natural question so I don't know where
changes are going to occur but somehow
when the search engine tries to crawl
fresh content from the from the web it
has to focus on the right aspect
otherwise it will end up being stale so
here's another example from social
networks once again on a daily basis
friendships are formed and broken right
so millions of links are modified each
day so and suppose I don't work for
Twitter but I want to track all the
friendships and Twitter as a third party
person which users today focus on who do
the changes most such that maybe i can
compute some global reputation likes a
pagerank so of course I can't go and get
the data from Twitter on mass but
instead if I use my resources available
and a judicious manner then I will be
able to make the best use of what what
changes exist there and this scenario is
not you need to either web or social
networks it occurs in every pretty much
every network no communication patterns
or traffic networks and so on in fact it
even occurs in like settings like public
opinion right I mean everybody has some
opinion about a topic and of course
these opinions keep changing all the
time and there's no way to track all the
changes simultaneously the only thing we
can do is ask a few people what they
think about the topic so these are some
motivating examples of why we need to
look at
evolving data so i couldn't come up with
a better name but i want to call this
like the evolving nature of algorithms
as what do you want to whatever to
convey in this talk is actually not more
about the algorithms per se but here is
a slightly new model of computation that
you can start playing with so once again
the data here changes slowly over time
and the goal we have is to compute some
function of data or each point in time
so i'll give you a more concrete example
in the next couple of slides so what is
the power of the algorithm the algorithm
actually can query the data at a few
points it has the ability to query you
can query the data and try to find out
what is the latest value in that
position of course the algorithm does
not know whether it is changing so this
seems completely you know algorithm has
no hope of doing anything because the
data can change adversary early right
but if we put some restrictions on how
the data changes and if you give some
more power to what the algorithm can
output for example we don't expect the
exact answer may be an approximate
answer or a random and solution then we
can show that we can do a bunch of stuff
so this model actually we studied in a
work few years ago for some like scalar
problems exciting and so on and then we
extended this model to some couple of
graph problems and connectivity and
minimal spanning tree and then more
recently we looked at a page rank in
this model and then I'll try to present
the pigeon acting you okay so here is a
formal description of the model so the
data arrives over a period of time and
let xt be the true data at time p and
our goal is to compute some function f
on this XT to produce a value say YT and
we assume that the input changes slowly
the input changes can be stochastic or
maybe even adversarial but we don't know
any examples for that the only
requirement is that the successive
changes between two timestamps is small
so these some distance and of course
I've stated this in the most general
terms so X can be a graph X can be a nom
oryx can be a matrix or whatever so the
D you see here will actually depend on
the domain that you are working with but
the restriction is that the D the
distance function actually small so
you're not talking about huge changes
that occur every time and it's not a big
restriction because you can make time as
small as you want and what is the power
of the algorithm the algorithm can make
limited probes into the data at a
particular time so think of the
algorithm and the and nature operating
in tandem so step at each step the
nature makes a change the algorithm has
ability to make one probe yeah yeah even
great idea they were the only question
is the only interesting thing is that
what things too no no no it's completely
you can probe limited means the number
so right now we just look at one change
per time step so but we can trade off
the rate of change of the data versus
the probing rate of the algorithm no no
that's so the algorithm is completely
oblivious to the changes sorry of course
I mean yeah you have to keep in mind
that if the changes are if the problem
is set up such the changes are
adversarial then no algorithm can do
anything because you're getting too much
power to the changes so they have to be
the right balance so that it makes
interesting statements so fundamentally
you need the fact that f is sort of sort
of continuous with exterior with x-ray
yeah exchange is a little
should not change yeah yeah yeah exactly
some kind of a [ __ ] so okay so the
algorithm maintains approves the data
and then it's allowed to do whatever I
mean we don't have any we don't restrict
on that space or time usage so it can
maintain a complete snapshot of what it
thinks that it is and then it's only
goal is to output some solution y y
prime of T and which should look like
whitey I mean this looks a way to
partial modern right because how is it
even possible to do guarantee such a
thing okay any other questions for the
model exactly yeah yeah so the only
question is what information I caramel
okay so the model [ __ ] addressed in a
morp in more general terms but for
graphs here is what we look at so we
look like unweighted directed graphs and
at G sub P be the graph at time T so you
assume a few things again for analysis
and simple three purposes we assume the
notes that does not change so V is fixed
there are no new nodes are added or
deleted and you also seeing that the
number of edges does not change you
assume that the edge the h6 size is
fixed but of course it just it just
could appear at a scale so yeah you use
e to denote the size of it is set and
the assumption of data are not changing
too much translates to this thing the we
assume that take it whatever way network
or matrix or whatever e sub P plus 1
minus e sub T is small so the changes is
limited and I said before it's not a big
deal because can choose to be a very
small and we don't particularly assign
any specific change model I mean the
change model will really depend on if
the change model again is like to
general we can't do much so what are the
results we get will depend on the change
model and what about the algorithm so
time p the algorithm can probe any node
you and get its current set of neighbors
and it actually should be any sub T of
you so all they're just an e sub T of
the form u comma B so you can just get
the neighborhood of a given node so this
is the
in decorative so so is there an
assumption that at some point you see
the full ground no no no it's a country
so you never know the program not you're
just observing yeah that in fact there
is no photograph right so you just keep
changing did you know he's 0 oh yeah we
assume that initially I mean again for
simplicity we can assume you know g0 but
it's not really needed because yeah so
you can assume that you start over the
same graph ok so this model ok so as a
session they pointed out the only
question here is what should be the
probing strategy how should I prove the
notes in what order or who should be the
next guy to probe and that really
depends on two things one of our first
of all what is the change model like how
do I assume that it is changes between x
times now touch-ups and then what is
actual goal what is the function you
want to compute ok so here is a more
cocktail example so jennifer is pointing
out the assumption here is that the
rhythm starts off with a graph that it
knows the correct So Ji Won be the graph
so algorithms view of the world is the
same but the world changes so this edge
disappears and a new edge arrives but
the algorithm for some reasons chooses
to query this node so it doesn't see the
change and the next time step this edge
disappeared in a new age arrived but at
this time step the algorithm was lucky
enough to query the green know so it got
it gets the previous update from the
previous 10 step and so on you know in
the next step some other that spider
that can it just shows here and
algorithm was lucky enough to get the
blue agent at the rate so this is maybe
at a particular time and here is what
the algorithm thinks the draw phase and
here's what the graph is actually right
so somehow it doesn't know anything more
and but it has to compute some function
but what what ordering should the
proving be done
okay so i will give two concrete
examples of this paradigm the first is
st connectivity so here the problem is
you're given two specific notes SNT in
the graph and you want to maintain a
path from s to t to specific notes and
here is a change model so you assume
that the edges at t plus 1 is obtained
in the following way you pick a random
page from the current graph and pick a
random knowledge from the current graph
and then you swap them so basically take
it take out an existing edge and put in
an edge that one didn't exist before and
this is because you want to be can
handle knowledge because we assume for
simplicity that the the graph size
doesn't change the number of edges so
just wait them so a couple of things are
to make the problem interesting a
non-trivial we have to assume two things
first of all you eat assume that the
number of edges is at least n log n
otherwise you won't even hit
connectivity and number of edges is not
too big like not more than n root n
because the number of edges too big then
basically everybody has a comedy so the
interesting regime is where the number
which is between these two so as as I
said before the model is like each node
gets a label ok and here's algorithm so
think of this algorithm as proceeding
independently ok the graph evolves one
at each time but algorithm doesn't even
look at the graph I mean doesn't even
pay attention to the progress
progression of the graph but just these
things does this in panel so first it
tries to grow a ball BS around the
source node s of roughly square root of
n over log in side visited nodes whereby
visited again the following tane you
take in your current bal you take the a
visitor node pick the closest unvisited
node and then prove that node and add
all its neighbors asks into this current
one that's my ball bearing out
and similarly grows another ball BTW
around t of similar size so you can show
that under these graph growth
assumptions that roughly these two balls
of like sighs sighs square root I'm
right so in expectation they should have
actually a common laborer and therefore
you can expect that the intersection of
this boss is not empty therefore I can
just use the non empty intersection to
construct a path from s to T I don't put
it so that's what it does so album just
proceeds like like this and so of course
in steps but remember the rhythm is
supposed to output a path at every step
right so you can assume that it will
output the last path it knows about the
only question is how do I make sure that
it is not an egg way to off right and
that's not actually too difficult we can
show that the probability that the
generated path is invalid I mean no over
the time steps is something like 1 over
square root n log N and that's that is
because of the way we assume the graph
grows its if you think about it the
graph is more like a gnm graph as time
progresses it's more like a random graph
of degree out to be total number of
edges to be exactly n so using such
properties you can actually show that
the path output at every step is not too
bad Oh in fact actually you can improve
on this so that is instead of me gaining
one path between S&T you are 0 for some
fault tolerance you ready meeting two
disjoint st paths and it's like there
are no power of two choices you can show
that the that's the that's a significant
improvement in the error probability can
show that the generated path is invalid
with probably utmost like no login / n
and one can ask like maybe I can try to
maintain like a pass but it can also
show lower bound that any algorithm is
of this form thing is the probing
algorithm has to have an error of this
something like login / n log log squared
n so it's basically tight so you can't
hope in too much of all these things
yeah
and so the point I want to make here is
that this SD card activity is sentencing
problem but if you choose the model
carefully then you can do some things
non-trivial with that okay okay so let
me switch to my second example which is
page rank so you have no choice but to
see another definition page jacket so so
let me go through quickly so you know
that page rank pi is a stationary
distribution of the random walk so it's
probably one minus epsilon you pick one
of the neighbors at random and then go
to the neighbor and with remaining
property go to a uniform log so assume
that teleportation and sodium and the
stationary see page rank so it can be
written in this matrix form matrix
vector form and I don't need a motive
eight pages and again like efficient
David did a wonderful job with that so
it's a well motivated now what's the
goal here the goal is to compute page
rank on an evolving graph so the graph
keeps changing and I need to cut out put
a vector x such that it's pretty close
to the truth and what natural notion of
what truth is of course I will outputs I
Prime and you look at the maximum error
between these two vectors like how much
each coordinate deviates them so they'll
infinity norm of Phi Prime and Phi and
you can also look at the l1 norm and we
insist that I should be able to bound
how much know how much I'm off from the
truth that's known and the way these
algorithms are even the previous
algorithm book is that they don't get
anything fancy in terms of you know
working at the graph they just maintain
a view of what they think is a truth and
they work with that graph so it's that
even this algorithm will do the same
thing you maintain a view J prime of
what it thinks the truth gee what time T
is and you compute PI prime as a page
rank of G prime and then output that a
solution okay so that's the group and
what what can we do here I mean what is
the one other what is that what is the
flexibility and freedom we have here the
key observation is that a high PageRank
node has more effect
paging of other notes so in fact know
some of these things are actually
motivated by ashes work with mom and on
the the basic computing updating pigeon
first so if you look at this equation pi
of you is proportional to PI of me over
degree and therefore if if a time p this
value is large and v is changing the ads
or deletes a node then it will have a
huge impact on pi of you therefore nodes
with high page rank are the candidates
to query right that's the natural
intuition ur remember that but we don't
have access to PI T that what that's
what makes it tricky Bureau via yeah
that's just two pi primer prime of T we
don't have another axis is the truth
only have access to the approximation
but if we assume truth is like
approximation at time T then this leap
from PI to PI prime may not be a bad one
so that naturally reads leads to the
following algorithm they call it the
proportional probing so here's I here
return that pipe ramp looks like pie
okay and then at time T you pick a node
v2 Pro with probability proportional /
Prime at the previous time step then of
course update your view of the world
with this new query and its neighbors
and then compute page rank on this new
graph may be using Ashish is fast
algorithm and then and then then more to
the next step right so business is this
a good thing to do right so it quick
detour so this other than is
probabilistic but actually can make a
deterministic by a standard trick so
this leads to a slightly better
algorithm called be called priority
probing so it can think of it like a
determinist deterministic version of the
previous algorithm so initially
everybody has zero priority okay and I
thank time T so made in a heap at time T
pick the node with the highest priority
so let v be the note of the highest
priority you probe V and obtain all its
neighbors and on output G Prime and T
and so on and output a page rank
and then you reset the notes priority to
zero and increment priority of everybody
else by the pipeline so sort of like V
has been probe so it sort of goes down
in the queue and then everybody else
increases proportional to walk bethpage
I'm gonna suffer which one everybody all
the nodes young everybody huh so so what
you can show is that um you can show
that this deterministic scheme still
picks each node with the right no
measure not only that but you won't have
the bad effects of randomization there
also guarantee that every node is these
picked at least once in like order of 1
over its page next steps so you won't
have the unlucky instances here so it
never miss a probing a set of nodes
because because of randomness so just a
small detour anyway so one of those
analysis so again like we have to be
careful with what the change one will be
assumed to be able to prove something's
so here is a change what we assume so
each time T you pick an edge uniformly
at random from the graph and then you
want to really get the reorient here
that age and the way we do that is if
they can know W with probability
proportional to its patron in the true
graph and then redirect UV to UW so
basically if you notice I pagerank it
has a higher chance of getting a new
edge very rich get richer sort of thing
and then this you might argue with why
this is the right model but this is a
model body can actually show something
interesting you can show that in the
steady state the yeah actually should be
by primesonic the approximated pagerank
vector is given that given the truth at
time t minus 1 and my version of truth
is very close to the actual truth of the
patient
right suppose you had a system of linear
equations and changing over time are you
effectively just beginning solution
approximate solution I sort of do I
don't know how to yeah I it might work
out but I don't I don't know that's a
good point yeah so this is the this is a
guarantee and maintain so you can show
that the solution computer is not far
from the truth even though you never see
the truth so in fact I don't want to
bore you with any experiment I didn't
show any graph so on but there are there
in the paper but you can see so this
hour the machine does pretty well we
tried on some some large graphs and
cream maybe when some subset of Twitter
maybe it does pretty well actually
because the changes that happen in the
real world graph are not too far away
from this actually no they are not real
adverse serious no they are random and
Sampson may not be in this sense but
they are sort of a random so all right
and the proof of this actually uses the
data bank interpretation from ahsha shin
ramen sniffles okay so I want to
conclude my talks with a few things so I
hope I convince you that evolving graphs
actually is an interesting model is
worth looking at even some basic
problems and the question is can you
obtain like more interesting algorithms
for like maybe more non trivial problems
on such a model for example clustering
coefficient or no between us and
centrality things that are studied very
much in social network literature also
community trying and constraint so
thanks